last two lectures but with
a very different approach that will
hopefully avoid the machinery and so you
know the last one i kind of accelerated
as time went on
uh partially became you know largely was
because it was not one lecture worth of
material that i was trying to get in
there and so i think the biggest selling
point from about to talk about today is
that it or this part is that it actually
is
that i'm going to
if i don't get to sidetrack more or less
give you a full proof of an entire
laplacian solver in the course of one
lecture uh
modulo uh the construction of a low
stretch spanning tree which i think i'd
only need another 15 minutes for to get
an almost linear algorithm so let me
kind of tell you how to do this without
preconditioning and this talk is based
on recent work with let's see if any of
them are in the room uh with uh aaron
said for lorenzo orecchia and zawanzu
there's aaron
um okay so
anyway uh what's the idea
uh the idea is actually i'm gonna try to
do a combinatorial algorithm instead of
a numerical one um
and you know the last one i buried a lot
of the combinatorics inside the
construction of a low stretch spanning
tree and recursive preconditioning here
we're going to make it very explicit and
what's i think interesting about it is
that it's intrinsically a different
structure it's not i won't say the
previous ones were in some sense
multi-grid ish they weren't quite
multi-grid multi-grid they but they had
the same moral feeling they were
preconditioning with some structural
understanding
of the kind of combat of long paths and
then using some sort of core structure
and fine structure this is nothing like
that
um and it's not going to use any of the
machinery i developed it won't be
recursive it won't be
uh conjugate gradients at all but you'll
see that actually the intuition has
certain strong overlaps and the whole
algorithm is really just going to fit on
a blackboard actually the whole
algorithm is going to require a nice
spanning tree where nice is a low
stretch spanning tree and for people who
missed the last one i'll remind you what
low stretch spanning trees are
so it's going to all it's going to do is
take a nice spanning tree and then it's
going to be an iterative procedure that
is about five lines of pseudocode
and
data structure
a very simple lightweight data structure
and that will give us a linear algorithm
uh the convergence proof is not going so
the last one i actually really hid the
convergence proof like i waved my hands
out of recursion and then waved my hands
at an ability to analyze the recursion
and then said make all your numbers
infinite precision um and so here the
convergence proof is there's an energy
it goes down every step by a
multiplicative factor so if you do that
enough it gets small and if it's on one
blackboard um and no chebyshev
polynomials no recursive preconditioning
no conjugate gradient okay that's the
setup uh let me give a couple quick
comments the first one is that numerical
stability of this
is super easy to prove which i think is
nice so the other one actually not only
was it non-trivial it's
not it's sort of i said not known it's
probably known by richard
uh
and
eventually will exist um like it's super
hard to so the algorithm i gave in the
last analysis uh to really make it
rigorous in using things that are
already out there in the literature you
need to use poly logarithmic precision
so it was you know n log squared and
arithmetic operations but each of them
took a little longer if you do them with
if you get charged for your arithmetic
that's probably unnecessary and at least
for the ones that i described before uh
richard says he can make the analysis go
through but it's really not trivial it
takes some real work
and it's going to be a completely easy
analysis here
when you charge for eye precision
arithmetic and pretend that you don't
get to talk to richard offline this
would then i think when in in the model
where you get sort of charged for
you know doing arithmetic with actual
words um
and it's a little slower if you don't so
it's going to be an extra lab factor or
two slower
and i also think the approach is
probably applicable so we're going to do
is we're going to open up the black box
of the solver and instead of just
sort of recursively preconditioning
things and then kind of looking at the
high level numerics what we're going to
do is actually
open everything up and instead of taking
a bunch of these very expensive
iterations
sorry a small number you know if you
think i want to solve
something in n polylog on time if i'm
going to do that then i kind of need to
make the number of iterations be
logarithmic because otherwise you know
each iteration is going to at least take
the time to write down the whole vector
and multiply matrix vector
product so it seems like you're stuck
with a small number of expensive
iterations linear time iterations here
we're actually going to not do that what
we're going to do is we're going to
shoot for a linearist number of
logarithmic time iterations and that's
going to make our life very much easier
um and the basic setup is how i think we
teach people not to solve linear
equations which is you want to solve ax
equals b you find a constraint you know
one of the
rows dotted with x equals b i that's
violated you find it you fix it and you
repeat and that's actually essentially
the whole algorithm uh the it's going to
replace all this and what's interesting
also is you have to i said before you
should look for where the lines go you
know that line graphs are your problem
the recursive precondition one did it by
the
greedy elimination step and the
recursion right here what we're going to
do is do it with a very simple data
structure
and uh what's going to happen is that
the sort of recursive preconditioning
and small number of large iterations can
become
a simple data structure which actually
you can think of as choosing the right
basis to work in and then a large number
of very simple ones simple iterations
okay so now i want to just remind you of
some background that i think was in a
couple of the other talks but it's
important enough for them to do and it's
quick so i just want to put it up so i
want to remind you laplacians and
electrical circuits and how they relate
so
you know the general setup is recall we
can interpret
uh the laplacian in terms of electrical
circuits the idea is that you take your
edges of your graph and you declare the
resistors
uh you make the resistance of an edge
with weight w be one over its weight
right so a
bigger edge can carry more stuff and has
lower resistance
and then
uh in this algorithm i'm not going to
use very much about electrical circuits
i'm only going to really use a couple
very simple facts about them
one of them is that
you know what do you get when you do put
electricity on a graph so what we're
going to do is we're going to tie a
battery to the acid and t or a current
source to s and t
and you know you have two numbers that
dictate what's going on you have a
potential vector the voltages which is a
number assigned to vertices you have a
current vector which assigns a flow um
to the edges
um and
then if we let chi sub v
be the net current out of a vertex v
then those will call the demands so
you know think
current that comes into or out of the
grass
and for simplicity during the talk
um it's nicer when you draw electrical
circuits to not have current coming into
and out of every vertex so i'm probably
fairly consistently throughout the talk
i'm going to
make the demands that we're trying to
solve
the uh
chi st is sort of in one unit of current
into s and out of t so you can think of
that as solving lx equals a vector
that's got a one a negative one and a
whole bunch of zeros
um
literally nothing i do today is going to
have any dependence on that other than
it means when i draw my pictures i can
the electrical analogy is a little
clearer to see everything is linear so
if that works for that it's actually
kind of forced to work for everything
else but it'll just make a little bit
cleaner to draw stuff
okay so what do we uh need to know about
electricity so
the answer is that it exists and it
produces
these numbers right it could produces a
set of voltages in a set of currents and
the main properties we're go we're going
to need are the following one is that
it's related to laplacians that
certainly would be useful for solving
laplacians and what we're going to see
is that uh so one thing it's true and i
think nikhil said was
that if you solve the linear system l v
equals chi
that um correspond the answer v
is the set of electrical potentials
you'd get if i took an electrical flow
that routes the man's chi so if i solve
lv equals chi st the one and the
negative one thing then the vector v is
going to be the
voltages you would get if you
tie the battery i should call this a
current source for people who
actually uh notice that um right you
said one unit of current from s to t and
v is the voltages
um
okay the other thing is
electricity the real property we use
about electricity is that it obeys ohm's
law
so it says that there are these voltages
v and
the electrical flow on an edge is v i
minus v j over the resistance right so
the potential difference divided by the
resistance
um and
uh we're also going to look at the
energy dissipated by an edge so this is
just
um you know you take this is the i
squared r so it's the flow squared on an
edge times the resistance which from the
above equation is the potential
difference squared divided by the
resistance
that is the uh
power dissipation
uh by an edge
um
and you'll notice that this directly
ties to
the transpose lv
right so okay that's all we're going to
need about electricity the main points
are
there's an energy function which happens
to be v transpose ld the energy
dissipated by a single edge is just it's
the edges contribution to that
electrical current so they flow
conservation
and there they are a flow uh that comes
from the potentials and you'll notice
that you know this actually
characterizes them as kind of a crucial
point note that most flows are not given
by potentials you know most flows do not
have the property that the flow on an
edge can be written consistently as a
potential difference divided by a fixed
resistance
um and the main fact this algorithm is
going to look at about all of this is
just that you could by taking one
derivative notice that i've written
you know one way to describe the answer
to the question l v equals chi is to
minimize its energy
and so in particular you could either
characterize the electrical flow as a
solution to a linear system
um or you could characterize it by the
single the flow that routes your demands
and minimizes energy
are there any questions on that
i did that a little quickly because i
think everybody most people here already
know what i'm talking about on this but
tell me if
i missed anything
okay so that's actually all we're gonna
need about electrical circuits
um and
so
this was our setup and
the
uh main property we're going to use
about this whole setup is just that
voltages are very restrictive
right the unique flow that has voltages
um is the electrical flow and
what why is that an actual restrictive
property well if i were to tell you an
arbitrary flow then if i you know if i
look at the flow on a bunch of on a
bunch of different paths between two
vertices
they probably tell you different things
about how far apart what the potential
difference should be between the
vertices right if something comes from
voltages then in particular if i if all
the flows actually are voltages you know
the flow on every edge tells you the
potential difference around the edge and
so in particular if i take any cycle in
the graph and what i do you know f e r e
is the potential difference as i go
along the edge if i go around a cycle i
certainly should get back where i
started any potential right if i start
at a given point i say
what's the new potential as i traverse
the cycle if they actually are
consistent potentials i'll get zero
right
that is actually essentially the whole
algorithm our algorithm is going to just
use that fact over and over so
all the recursive preconditions can be
replaced with the following algorithm uh
randomly cycle
randomly sample a cycle c from a
distribution i'll tell you about shortly
uh check if when you go around that
cycle your flow
so we're going to try to instead of
finding the potentials we're going to
try to find the electrical flow
so we're not going to compute v we're
going to compute f and then we're going
to use that to find v by
uh exactly these equations by taking
potential differences and all you'll do
is just randomly sample a cycle check if
when you take your flow when you go
around the cycle it's consistent it gets
back to where it started
um if it isn't fix it how do you fix it
well you add the appropriate multiple of
the cycle to the flow to fix it
um and then you repeat and that turns
out to give another linear time
algorithm for laplacian systems
good
okay so now let me actually fill in a
little bit more in the details so here's
my graph um and again i'm going to draw
this with smt and to make this a little
more precise this is a slightly course a
slightly finer grained overview and then
i'll fill in one more round of details
uh what you're going to do is your
algorithm is you're going to initialize
it with any reasonable sp flow so here a
path is the right thing the shortest
path for example
um
and then the algorithm will do the
following it will
call that a flow right so i want to
route the demand so i want to route one
unit from s to t
start with anything that writes the
demands a short say a good path and then
this is a flow but it's not the answer
right and the reason it's not the answer
is if i go around cycles in the graph
it's clearly not conserving potential
but when i drew arrows on the graph note
this is still an undirected graph this
is just when i talk about potential
differences and flows i know what sign
to put on the value
so again don't the arrows are there to
indicate which way flow is going it's
still an undirected graph
um okay so the algorithm is repeatedly
do the following randomly sample a cycle
um and then compute as i said before
compute the sum around it so here you'll
notice that let me do this in the two
steps notice that as you go around this
cycle you don't get back where you
started you get two instead of zero
right
um so what we're gonna do is add the
right multiple of the cycle to fix that
so it's like two sevenths maybe um and
you end up with this
so now we have fixed the cycle now you
go around this cycle and it
is still it adds up to zero but you've
probably broken something else and just
gonna repeat so to turn this into an
actual legitimate algorithm what are the
main things i need to do so i need to
tell you what cycles to use
and tell you what probability
distribution to use to sample them
i need to tell you how to implement the
updates so
in particular these cycles could be
quite large there's no you know it's
possible that the cycle could include
most of the edges in the graph and it
would be nice to
not pay in to update a cycle but just to
pay logan no matter what cycle you have
and that's actually a very easy data
structure
and then the last thing i need to do is
convince you that you don't need to do
this too many times
and so to sort of put the whole talk
into for both points the cycles we use
are going to be the cycles formed by
adding an edge to a low stretch spanning
tree so um and i'll do these all the
more depth uh the sampling probabilities
we use is that i'm going to sample each
cycle with a probability proportional to
the stretch plus one the plus one means
essentially you're counting the edge too
so it's the total length of the cycle
uh the updates are going to be a simple
data structure
link cut trees would suffice but are
aggressive overkill um they're way more
complicated than necessary and the
number of iterations is just going to be
um nearly linear and it's going to
roughly be proportional to the stretch
of the tree
and
that's it
okay so now let me
go one more level of filling in the
details for each of these so i want to
remind people what the spanning trees
and cycles
and stretch are just because the last
lecture that got a little bit compressed
and i don't want to compress it too much
here at all because it's really the only
combinatorial the only piece we really
need
um so you know if you're given the
standing tree
uh first of all i claim forev this gives
us a basis for the space of cycles so
for every edge that's not in the tree
you get a cycle
right um and you get a path so i give
you this edge e and i fix the tree then
i get that on the right p e for the path
in the tree that routes the edge
so
um right so this is p e and you can also
get a cycle which is just you know
putting the edge into the path
and so you have this you know so given
every edge not on the tree you got a
cycle
and you get a path from the tree and the
stretch as i said last time but i'll say
it a little bit more slowly this time
the stretch is the ratio think about the
ratio of how
far apart the vertices are if you sort
of route in the tree or route along the
edge itself so what it is it's the ratio
of the length of the path where you
measure length and resistance
the total resistance of the path and the
resistance of the edge itself
and it's that ratio so in particular if
let's just for a second pretend the
graph is unweighted for simplicity in
that case the stretch of an edge is just
the length of the path that wraps it in
the tree
um
and then uh so you're six you can then
define a cycle which just adds in one
more edge you can get the cycle
resistance which just
adds in it's just the total resistance
of the whole cycle
um including the edge and note that's
just the resistance of the edge times
one plus the stretch
and then it's actually not a bad idea
for much of this talk just to pretend
your graph is unweighted because it
makes the picture clearer but nothing we
use will depend on that
um and here you know the cycle has
resistance seven
um and then we can define the total
stretch of the tree to just be the sum
of the stretch of all the edges
including the trace um and the number
that's actually going to dictate our
performance is going to be
the
stretch of the tree plus
m minus two n plus two so as long as you
don't have a
as long as you don't have a super sparse
graph just think of this as stretch of t
uh so
this is just here so i can say something
formally correct but think of it as just
stretch of t
um
and remember the stretch of t has to be
at least 10 just because you're
including all the edges so just think
stretch of t but this is the formerly
correct one
okay so low strength spanning trees as i
showed last time you know there's
different ways of putting a spanning
tree on a graph and they're not all
equally good for what we're going to
talk about and the property we care
about is the total stretch and so for
the grid i drew this one which you'll
see has total stretch end to the 1.5
again because all sort of at least half
the vertices are stretched by like root
n over 2 or something
and then the good thing to do is the one
that captures the locality and the graph
structure correctly and you'll notice
that this is actually where all the
combinatorics is buried so last time i
promised that we were using graph
structure a lot and then i didn't have
to talk too much about graphs other than
effective resistances
and where did the grassy compositions
and whatever that i promised go they
come into the construction of low
stretch banding trees
and i
not sure if i'll have time to do them i
have slides after my last slide with
them and i'm happy to show them to
people and if i
accelerate enough during the talk i
might get to them but most likely i
won't they're not that complicated but
they are strongly using the
combinatorial structure for the graphs
okay so
the assertion reviews is that in very
close to linear time we can find a good
low stretch band entry and it's it's
just a basically a collection of
breadth-first searches
it's not a
it's not a real we're not really burying
anything super complicated inside of it
from an algorithmic standpoint like it's
not slow um
okay so
like there aren't hideous constants here
okay so now it's down the number of
iterations
um so how about the number of iterations
it's really just a potential function
argument so the idea is we're going to
define an energy right we're trying to
do minimization we're trying to minimize
the energy over all st flows so we're
going to do is we're going to forget
that we were actually doing linear
system solving
and looking for vertices we're just
going to look for
the flow that minimizes the energy over
all flows that radar demands we're here
we're making an st for simplicity
um and we're just going to track the
energy
so what we're going to track the energy
what we want to show is
that it
we're going to look at essentially the
difference between our present energy
and the optimal energy and we're just
going to show what goes down
multiplicatively every step to do that
we need to have some way of
understanding a bound on
the optimal energy like we have to know
how far we have to go so we're going to
write down the dual so if that's our
primal optimization problem you can
write out the dual what is r
r is the resistance of the action
so it's one over the weight
oh i i i see so that little r
that
is is the vector of resistances
um so right so the the r e assigned so i
meant that r yeah what why is oh this is
a definition
i wrote it sub r to indicate that it
depends on the rate
um
yeah
okay right so that's just the definition
of energy with respect to the
resistances
um
and the dual is just the dual it's a
pretty simple tool actually and if you
look at what it's doing it's other than
a kind of annoying scaling you should
think of it as
like here's kind of the intuition for it
the intuition is that if you're you can
think of the energy of the electrical
flow on the one hand as you take the
flow that minimizes energy r squared you
know i squared r the sum of the
dissipated power overall flows you could
all and thick when you fix the sending
one unit of current alternatively you
could imagine that what you'll do is
you'll nail down
the potentials of s and t and then
you'll look at the minimum of
you know the potential this is this
should be equal to
the energy contribution for each edge
and you could describe the electrical
flow that sends a unit from s to t as
either the thing that minimizes the
energy overall flows or the thing that
says you fix the potentials
appropriately and then minimize the
energy overall potentials maybe you let
the spring sort of relax now the reason
it looks a little weird is that the
potential difference that gives one unit
of flow isn't one it's a thing with the
effective resistance in it right and so
you get this scaling
out of that but morally the point is
just that
um on the one hand you can minimize
overflows minimize energy overall flows
and get
um and you get sort of one side right a
feasible flow gives you an upper bound
on the on the energy and the effective
resistance or if i give you a collection
of feasible resistances that's a lower
bound
um because it's an upper bound on one
over the effective resistance and so
uh that's the primal of the duel does it
matter
um so the s and t here are here because
i said that for the picture i'm going to
be
routing chi st
um
uh what i should if i wanted to write
this in full generality all i would do
is just say overall close that wrap the
demands chi and keep every equation the
same okay so like the right equation
actually
this would just be kind on
um
it's just a little messier to have the
potential intuition when you're sending
stuff into and out of every vertex is
why i did that okay um but nothing i
write just erase every time you see a
one of the negative one just call it chi
and we're done like everything it will
change completely unchanged uh it'll go
through coming change
and we're just going to track the energy
um of the flow f versus the energy of
that
and
all we're really going to use is that
the primal is bigger than the dual um
so for any flow f and v
uh note that we could for voltages we
can compute an energy
um
and
or computed an objective a dual function
which more or less with energy with the
appropriate scaling right so given
voltages you get an upper bound given
flows you get a lower bound
they're appropriately compared right
this is a lower bound that's an upper
bound
and that's all we're going to use
so
we'll define the gap to be the duality
gap it's going to be the difference
between
our present estimate of how far we could
be like we have a present flow where we
look at the difference
between um
whatever we presently know it to be and
uh well the end what we actually have
right so this is between our imaginative
feasible potentials and a feasible dual
this is the difference between the two
and just note in particular
that um my lower bound on the dual is at
least
the actual answer right so this is
bigger than the actual distance from
optimality
and what we're going to do is we're just
going to show the following this is the
main inequality that gives us our
software it's that the gap is that what
we'll do is we're going to show that the
expected energy improvement in every
step
is going to be one over tau
so
um
slide that buried uh
uh okay so
i wanted i had a slide that said a
little bit more neurotically what the
potential what the probability
distribution was
so um i'll give you a probability
distribution in a second and the
expected energy improvement in one step
is just going to be um one over tau
where tau is the total stress is the
total stretch of the spanning tree
the number written out before um
with the m minus n two n plus one thing
thrown in and all we're gonna show is
that the gap is going to
multiplicatively decrease by at least
one over tau times the distance from
optionality
um and then that's it then you take tau
iterations
okay so
um to tell you the energy decrease of a
step
uh let me
just uh
first let's just see what happens with
one individual edge and then i'll tell
you a bit about the probability
distribution um so if i pick one off
tree edge e
then let's figure out what i want to
check is suppose i fix the spanning tree
i pick one off tree energy and i'm going
to ask when i fix that cycle what
happens to the energy right so the
algorithm is i'll pick an edge from some
distribution i'll look at the cycle go
around it and see what happens
and um the question is what does that do
to our actual energy so the how much
we're going to send around the cycle is
going to be the thing that will make the
cycle zero which will actually be the
thing that will optimally decrease the
energy and let's just define delta sub
ce to be the thing that should be zero
that isn't so it's gonna say that if i
take a fixed cycle delta of it will be
the thing that says you go around the
cycle and you add up what the potential
change is
along every edge and it's what you get
that it's what the difference around the
cycle is when it should be zero right
it's the sum of the potential drops
around the cycle those primes are on the
e's not on the
s and r
i don't know
yeah um
yes they are sorry
um they're just very super scripted uh
yes good
so it's it's just as i go around a cycle
it's what the potential difference is
when i go around it
um and each flow each unit of flow you
send around the cycle changes this by
the total resistance of the cycle right
so if i push one unit flow around the
cycle the total resistance is the change
in the
um in this quantity
there any questions on this people with
me
good
so
to make it zero you just what do you add
you add that thing over r8 times the
times the cycle to the flow the thing
that makes it actually equal zero and
you can check that that actually is the
thing that minimizes that
over all multiples of the cycle to add
this is the thing that makes the energy
go down the most
and you can check what does to the
energy if you just write out the algebra
on it the energy change is just the
stuff we corrected the delta ce squared
divided by capital rb divided by the
total resistance of the cycle
so c e is a cycle and
you're supposed to multiply a number of
isomers right so it's in flow space um
right so well c e is i'm adding
something to the flow so
the idea is the cycle doesn't add up to
zero so i'm going to push flow around
the whole cycle so what does it do to
the flow i actually have a multiple of
the cycle this is an indicator function
you should think this is an individual
yes
um
and
that's the change in the energy
just by writing it out so
um now let's start analyzing a bound on
how far we are from optimality
so
the algorithm we have this is how much
progress we make when we fix something
uh like when we fix one cycle this is
how much progress we do make
now let's compare it to how so to know
what has to happen we have to know
something that relates this value to how
far we are from optimality like we want
something that says
when you look at how far you are from
being optimal you can somehow relate
that number to the expected value of the
s over whatever distribution we choose
yeah so you describe like an
iteration update to f right and you
measure the gap
and it's a function of f assumption
function of v which
is you're not updating z as well um so
the algorithm doesn't need to yeah um
the
like the algorithm never has to during
the iterative part of it
uh do that so the algorithm really is i
pick a single cycle i'm going to pick
the cycles i might as well just say what
the probability distribution is because
energy
no it's going to decrease the primal
energy so the idea is what we're going
to say is
um i'm actually going to maintain only a
flow
um given just a flow i can compute a
number which is when i go around the
cycle what happens what's the potential
that i get back to what's the total
potential around the cycle
so um and that's
uh supposed to be zero but isn't that's
going to be this delta um and all
algorithmically you do is take that
number
divided by re and push that much more
around your flow all use of gaps and
stuff is just in the analysis
um and what you're going to show is that
when the duality gap is big you're going
to expect to have a lot of you're going
to expect that this will make a lot of
prime expenses
that the energy will go down a lot if a
lot of cycles are badly violated
does that make sense
like what their potential you get from
the spanning tree given a flow
somewhere in there is there a potential
that you generate given given a spanning
tree in the flow uh not yet
okay um not yet
not there
right so so far i haven't needed to
right so far all i needed to do is just
i'm just saying what happens when you
fix one cycle
and it doesn't depend on the spanning
tree at all this is just a function of
a cycle and then we'll see how we'll
talk about that when we actually relate
this back to the cycles we're getting
from the trade
right like right now this is true for
every cycle not just for three cycles
um okay so now let's get a bound on
distance from optimality
um and it's just going to be
more or less straight from the duels so
now this is the answer to gary's
question so somehow what we have to do
is convince ourselves we have to somehow
relate back to the distance from
optimality if we're going to say we make
progress that's 1 minus 1 over tau of
the way to get the answer and somewhere
along the line we have to bound how far
we are from the answer in terms of how
violated things are and what we're going
to do is we're going to take our present
flow remember it's a primal only
algorithm so far
in our analysis what we're going to do
is we're going to construct a collection
of potentials and remember potentials
will give us a dual vector
and then we're just going to use that to
be oh and then that's a feasible
let's say it's a feasible dual and we'll
use that to bound the gap
um and the straightforward calculation
we're going to do is going to show
the following that if i give you
um a fixed flow and a fixed voltage
again assuming i have them from
somewhere which we'll say in a second
then if i compare energy of the flow
minus
uh the
voltage the dual energy from the
voltages
then well i claim that this is the gap
you get between those two numbers so if
i give you flow and voltages and i just
compute the difference between their
energies
i claim it's got this very nice
interpretation so what does this nice
interpretation tell you
it tells you that you have two things
that are supposed to
match up they're supposed to be equal
one of them is the flow on an edge the
other is
the potential difference divided by the
resistance this sums over all the edges
in the graph
weighted by the resistance the
difference between those two quantities
squared so it's different between the
what the flow is and what the voltages
think the flow should be squared
um and
now in order to actually make this work
we have to figure out how we're going to
construct potentials
so the way we're going to construct
potentials is exactly what gary asked
about so again this is all just for the
analysis remember the algorithm really
is just
independently sample cycles from the
distribution i said before
um
how are we going to construct the
potentials what we're going to do is
we're going to use our low stretch
spanning trade
so we want potentials that match our
flows somehow right like we want to get
the best potentials to make these two
things match up but there aren't any
potentials of natural flow because
remember the whole point here was that
what we're going to do is kind of work
towards consistency we're going to
maintain a flow and work towards it
being specified by voltages
so if it actually ever match
consistently to any set of voltages we
get a zero that would be down but we're
good so we're going to do is just pick
something we know we can do consistently
and just use it as a guess so what we'll
do is we're going to take our tree
and note that as long as you don't have
any cycles you can always consistently
define voltages because you just start
at the root of the tree and you just
make the potential differences be what
they're supposed to be and they never
conflict because they're in cycles
consistently uniquely uniquely yes
um and so this is how we're going to
pick the potential so we're going to do
is we have our flow the potentials we'll
use for a dual band will just be the
ones you get by only looking at the tree
and using those to specify the potential
differences on the tree edges
and then everything else that that fixes
all the voltages
and
so i wrote this out the equation just
for later use we'll define the voltage
of a vertex
a to be the sub overall it's in the
graph you should pick a root might as
well make an s for this picture you'll
sum over all
um you'll take the path from s to a
you'll just sum the potential drops over
all the edges
um
does everybody does this make sense am i
with people living okay so
note that for an edge in the tree
this thing is zero right the fe
uh
is f-e-r-e so
this thing you know sort of value both
of this but rd the potential drop and
the act what's supposed to be one of
these are the same
um and for non-tree edges the nice thing
about it is that it's actually directly
something we can read off from the
delta cd that we talked about so the
difference between s-e-r-e the actual
value
and
the vi minus vj
i claim it's just the potential
difference as you go around the cycle
right because you know it's the two
paths that you use to get from one point
to the other the true path and the edge
so delta c e is just that value um and
so in particular the gap
uh between these potentials and the flow
is exactly the sum over all non-tree
edges
of delta c e squared over rd
right so what this says in words is it
says that if you're far from
our goal is going to be to minimize
energy which we'll think of as working
towards we have a flow and we're going
to work towards it being consistent with
potentials which are the optimality
constraints and this says if you're very
far from being consistently
sorry if you're far from
optimality in terms of energy that's the
same thing
as being
uh thought as violating a lot of these
cycle constraints fairly substantially
right you can write your distance from
optimality in terms of how much the
potentials don't agree along the tree
um okay so what what have we showed
we've shown now that
the difference between the flow
our present flow and our optimal flow is
bounded by the gap
um because of the gap and we've also
computed the gap
so now let me just say out loud very
precisely so i think my slide got varied
what our distribution is going to be so
the algorithm is all it's going to do is
the following it's going to take only
cycles from the
fundamental cycles of low stretch
spanning trade and it's going to sample
each cycle proportional to the total to
its stretch
plus one to its total stretch right so
you're just going to sample them
independently with that probability
and it's not going to change per
iteration it's just the fixed
distribution at the beginning you don't
have to recompute anything
um and then what we're going to do now
is just look at the expected improvement
in energy
so if we choose an edge e that's the
decrease in the energy we compute it and
we are go what we're going to do is
we're going to choose edge with
probability one over tau that was the
total i defined before this is to make
the probabilities add up to one and then
the ratio of r e to lowercase r the
total cycle resistance to the edge
resistance so the stretch of the edge
plus one
um and
now let's just look at the expected
energy improvement
the expected energy improvement is just
what it's the sum overall the edges not
the treating of the probability times
the improvement and if you write it out
what do you get we get exactly one over
tau times the sum of
uh delta ces squared over r
which is just one over tau times the gap
and that actually is a linear system
solver almost
um so what have we now done we've now
actually shown that our improvement is
one over tau times our gap so we've
shown that the primal energy improvement
is boundable in terms of the gap which
is a bound on how far we are from
optimal so we'll just fill that in right
so if i look at let's say di is the
difference
not you know dot the gap at our distance
from the actual act not our lower bound
on the oct then what we get is that the
accepted value of
um of d i goes uh
is multiplied by one minus one over tau
so d i is in each iteration where energy
our distance from optimal energy is and
what we just showed was that
for a given d i the expected value of d
i is less than or equal to one minus one
over tau times the expected value of d i
minus one
um and we have to be a little careful
with not screwing up our expected values
you can't really always multiply stuff
um but this one will work out so what
we'll do is we'll bound the initial
energy uh by the total stretch of the
tree times uh the optimal energy and
that's not too big a deal you just have
to pick a decent starting flow so here
our shortest path looks great
um and then the expected distance from
optimality the expected distance from
the optimal energy
is now just going to be by induction 1
minus 1 over tau of the k times our
starting energy
and so
in
you know so just do the standard
analysis of multiplication you get that
as cat if k is like tau times log
stretch over epsilon
then that you get with an excellent
functionality
um
and i haven't yet shown you how to
implement the the updates and stuff but
other than that that actually is the
whole algorithm
um are there any questions
yeah i was wondering whether
you could find a better starting point
in some way or the other that gives you
a better energy to begin with
a small number of steps
um
something like you know for example uh
iteration pre-conditioning with
three
it wouldn't surprise me if the answer
was yes
um so the way that i should have said to
do in the general case the easiest way
to do this
for arbitrary demands is to use the low
stretch spanning tree that's where our
initial voltages will come from
um so the way we'll get our initial
guess is actually going to be
our initial energy we'll get our initial
things um
from
routing along low stretch standing tree
you probably can do
better i mean i guess it's a trade-off
of how well much you want to work to get
the starting point and how
um
i would not be surprised if there was
something a little better you can do in
our paper we play with we shave off some
vlogs by actually
playing with things that look roughly
like your paper uh your your uh
your
um you know blown up treat paint but uh
we use some of that a little bit to
shave off some logs some of this is
a little bit less necessary because of a
paper that aaron and ginta lee wrote
that is going to shave off a couple more
logs anyway
um
at the end but yeah it's this is meant
to be a little bit crude and just give
us pop blogs
um there are slightly
yes um the question you have to worry
about is the overlap of them
so the thing that makes this a little
tricky to parallelize if you don't work
really hard at it i mean i would love to
parallelize this and i think that in
real life it's very plausible that it
could be paralyzed the theoretical
obstruction is that when you do the
updates you have to figure out you need
a lot of sort of non-intersection along
the cycle so you can simultaneously do
the updates or you need a data structure
that
will
handle all that somehow um
that's the main obstruction to
parallelization but it's not implausible
to me that this can be done i don't know
how to do it
um the other thing is note by the way
that i use the low stretch banding tree
note that if i gave you say a low
diameter graph like a power law graph i
wouldn't i could use a breath for a
search tree
so um i don't actually know another
algorithm that's substantially simpler
than the full cuda smeller painting or
one of the other recursively
preconditioned solvers that solves
parallelographs this uh take a breath
first search tree and randomly sample
cycles that's it right so it's even
non-trivial in sort of simple cases with
low diameter
um
okay so now let me just tell you the
last thing we need to know because i'm
going to browse a couple more steps so
for the low stretch tree now is where
the stretch comes in so the interesting
point is that you can run this algorithm
for any spanning tree but it only works
well for the right spanning tree um it
only works well for a low stretch
spanning tree because what we actually
got is the number of iterations is
proportional to the total stretch
um the uh and that gives analog straight
n
uh the log one of rep salon is nice to
have um
now note that you can actually
um
i made this a probabilistic algorithm
that we also probably improve the energy
every step but it's easy enough to check
what your error is because you can
compute a residual so you can turn this
into an algorithm with a probabilistic
run time and a promise that you'll get
the right answer as opposed to a
probably right answer with a fixed run
time um you can tighten the log factors
with a bit more work
um and really all that's left is for me
to convince you you can quickly update
cycles and maybe do lectures then
so
uh why do we need to do this
you might like it doesn't seem like we
necessarily even need a data structure
but the reason we need a data structure
is just that these cycles they are on
average fairly short i've promised you
that the average cycle is log n length
um but we're sampling them non-uniformly
we're sampling them with probability
proportional to their length so they're
actually biased towards the bad cycles
towards the ones that are big and so if
what we were going to do was actually
have to pay if we did the naive way
representing our everything kept a
vector of things on edges then we could
have to pay a lot for long cycles and
there's no obvious
reason why we could um expect each
iteration to be fast enough that we get
a good running time right like the
expected length of a cycle might be
bigger than we want it might not be long
enough because we're biased towards the
heavy cycles so all we need to do is
make a
data structure that fixes that
so oh the other thing is the stresses
are proportional to resistance so
uh and whereas the cost of updating the
data structure would be the number of
edges you touch so in weighted graphs
the
hope that low stretch will be also out
of this is even less related
um
okay so
let me tell you what the data structure
has to do so with the data so all we're
going to do is support very simple
queries
and again the data structure link cut
trees do this but they're dynamic trees
and they're complicated because they're
doing
very non-trivial things on dynamic trees
and we're only going to need static
trees because we never change the tree
or any of the numbers in this algorithm
so they're gross overkill and so there's
a very simple way to do this without
using them um so okay so what do we need
to be able to do we need to be able to
keep track of the flow and we need to be
able to quickly compute the sum around
the cycle of the potential drops
uh to do that um it's really enough to
be able to query and update the tree
potentials because the tree is where
something interesting is happening you
can just you can store each edge by
itself and just add it into the values
of the tree to get the things around the
cycle so the interesting behavior is
what happens on the tree
um and what we need to be able to do is
compute the voltages that you deduce
from the tree and then you can compute
everything else so we need to be able to
do is compute this va
which is the potential difference the
tree proposes between a pair of vertices
and we need to be able to do this in
time ideally log in so a time that
doesn't depend on
how far the vertex is from a on the
pathway and we want to be able to do
this with updates that add alpha units
of flow to a fixed edge so the idea is
that we want to be able to say here's a
little bit more flow on an edge and this
edge could be in a whole bunch of cycles
and a whole bunch of tree paths so we
don't want to have to pay for that
um so this is one of the operations like
countries support but it's like
aggressive overkill and it turns out you
can do it with a very simple data
structure and oh of login per operation
um and what's interesting actually is
the data structure itself is just as far
a nice basis for
it's actually a sparse linear algebra
basis for everything we write down
um okay so
uh let's see how much i have left 10
minutes
um
so i think with the last 10 minutes of
the talk i'm going to choose an
adventure
i can do either the data structure
um
or i can try to get a sketch of how to
construct low stretch spanning trees
slightly
uh so i'll take a pole or i could just
punt in the cave um
so
um
raise your hand for a punch raise your
hand for a low stretch spanning trees
um i will do the worst scenario the
combination of the two badly so
so this is the dab structure for a line
it just if it's the line is actually the
hard case for it roughly what you want
to be able to do the question you're
going to ask on a line is i want to be
able to do operations that add numbers
to these edges and i want to be able to
compute the sum of those numbers between
here and the end point
and basically you just build a binary
tree on top of the line
and then you keep track of the
cumulative sums um over the first total
vertices and you add a plot
that was the data structure badly
so again all it is it's basically just
that you take your tree you divide it in
half and you can um and repeat so for
this is for a line and the line is the
worst case
uh more generally you just build a
binary decomposition of your tree and
it's a little and you have to only add a
block and internals okay angela's fixed
fan trees which i will not rush quite so
badly
um so
uh this was my pontificate part of it uh
which was that no it doesn't use tree
preconditioners no low strap uh no um
it just it's not it's not actually using
the tree as a preconditioner but it's a
basis and it has no recursive anything
um i do want to mention that aaron and
cat have this beautiful paper that
speeds it up further so they get to take
a square root so they get um of the
number of iterations and what they do is
actually use
a coordinate to send the analog of
nesterod's method for accelerated
descent and i highly recommend their
paper um
and maybe they'll even talk about it at
the workshop by organizing later in the
semester
um but
uh okay so and that was why i brushed
aside the
can we speed up the starting points that
their paper gets around it um
okay so let me not do that and let me
jump ahead to constructing leather
stretch banding trees quickly so i have
about 10 minutes
i can do this um
okay so let me tell this is where the
combinatorics is actually buried i
remember i said you should worry about
what happens to lines here it's very
explicit what happens to lines what
happens to lines is our data structure
does them if i try to solve linear
systems on the line
then our that structure is just doing
them by hand so we're collapsing we're
just keeping
instead of doing some recursive thing
that buries it inside of the recursion
what we're doing is just maintaining a
cycle basis and so if you maintain a
cycle basis
then it's very then a cycle which
previously had a very complicated
stretch of the end and required sort of
recursion and stuff here human cycle
basis
while the cycle just gets a number and
you're adding up numbers per cycle and
so they're getting collapsed by hand um
let me see so to construct those for
expanding trees
what's the high odd light being here the
high level idea is that somewhere we
need to be able to um
sort of find the edges that are very
that are
um
that
let me get rid of this
okay so well the construction i'm gonna
give i will not give you the login one
that we actually use that's a little bit
of work
um what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give you an older one that will give a 2
to the root log n log log so just to
know what that is that's less than any
power of m
right
so it's like n it's less than n to the
epsilon note this log is like square
root of log n whereas
the log of any polynomial is like log n
so this is almost what i promised
it's you know n to a one plus little of
one as opposed to
polyloc and this has a much simpler
construction um and
i probably won't briefly specifically
get stronger guarantees the high level
idea um
this is exciting the high level idea is
that what we're going to do is we want
to capture the sort of link structure of
the graph we want to understand its
clustering
and so we're going to do is we're going
to partition the graph
into low diameter clusters without
cutting too many edges
and then once i give you that we're just
going to recurse
so the idea here is i want to get a
spanning tree that works well on yeah
that sort of captures the edge lights
well if the graph had low diameter a
breath first surgery would be great
because the graph has low diameter if i
tell you the diameter of a cluster then
certainly a breath for a search tree
won't stretch any edge by more than we
need twice
so what we'll do is we'll
partition the graphical diameter
clusters about cutting too many edges on
each of those clusters we'll build the
dfs tree and then we'll just collapse
the clusters to points in recurse
um so i should say about this is the
alone cart pallet west construction that
predated these things it was in a case
overhead right it's really nice okay so
um the partition is going to rely on two
things the main combinatorial core of
this is a ball growing procedure so it's
going to say so the real hard part is
well
both are sort of equally hard the core
kind of combinatorial fact that we're
going to use here
is that you can actually do this low
diameter clustering and that actually is
buried somewhere in every one of the
linear system having algorithms i know
of
um and what we're going to use is the
following one it's going to say given a
graph g we can partition it into
clusters with the following property
one is only one over t fraction of the
edges go between different clusters so
if i just cut it into the clusters i
don't cut too many edges
and two is that every cluster has small
radius
uh o of t log n
this goes back to
our buck and it's kind of kind of the
core
the analysis in a lot of sparse's cup
papers
um and
it's a certain classical ballground
construction how do we prove this
decomposition exists
the way we do it um
is as follows all we're going to do is
find it essentially greedily so we're
going to do is we're going to um
arbitrarily pick a starting vertex x and
we're just going to we want a low
diameter cluster around it we're just
going to build it really so we're going
to start at a vertex x
and we're going to look at a ball of
radius one two three four five six seven
and we're going to stop when either we
get the whole graph or
we get a cut that meets our condition
so you're going to keep growing the ball
until either
um
until either you have the whole graph or
you can find
a cut that sort of gets the right
fraction of edges so let's define the
ball to be the ball i just described for
now let's just pretend everything's
unweighted
um it's just easier to describe
and um let's look at the edges that go
from the ball of radius r the ball of
radius r plus one
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
look at how many edges you cut if you
just pull out that one cluster so that's
the ratio of the edges that go out of
the ball to the volume of the ball
now again our goal is going to be to
construct to cut a small fraction of the
total edges
so here we'll look at just this for this
single ball's contribution to edges that
are cut and vertices that we remove
um and we're just going to look at the
cuts and we're going to stop growing for
the first time that we sort of get the
legitimate thing we're hoping for that
the number the ratio of edges cut to
volume is
less than the asserted the allowed ratio
that we're shooting for so for shooting
for the for this lemma we're not going
to use it with these parameters but it's
convenient to think of it think of um
your that association you can cut into
logarithmic diameter clusters where you
cut half the edges and so we'll look
here the first time where the ratio of
edges we cut to volume is
bounded by that so
then all you're going to do is just
remove that ball and repeat and i claim
this gives us our damn our clustering
and the real point is just whenever we
remove first of all whenever we remove
edges we're moving t times as much
volume so if this actually works we may
i haven't yet promised you the low
diameter thing but at the very least i
haven't cut too many edges because every
time i cut some edges i remove enough
volume to
uh to compensate for it
and now i claim that if you don't stop
it means that the volume of the ball is
growing pretty quickly right so although
the volume means total edge weight
contains not vertex weight um so the
idea is that what does it mean that i
kept going what does it mean that i
increased my radius by one it meant that
actually i got a lot more edges when i
grew the ball because if the volume
didn't decrease increase a lot when i
grew the ball one more step
then that would have meant there weren't
too many edges leaving the ball and i
would have had a sparse cut
so if i don't stop that means e i over
volume of b is one over t at least one
over t
and so in particular it means that the
total volume when i add in these new
values goes up by one plus one over t
right so the point is one of two things
happens in each iteration either you get
a lot more stuff or you don't
if you don't then you call it a cot if
you do then the ball grew a lot and then
in particular no this can't happen too
many times you'll just get rid of f
right so i keep going at radius r the
volume is one plus one over t to the r
and so that can't happen more than t log
n times or i'll just have too many total
edges
and that's the proof
so this tells me there are low diameter
clusterings
um i'm going to skip dealing with
multiplicities you have to be a little
careful because we're collapsing
clusters you have to deal with multi
graphs correctly
it's not
a big deal uh but you have to do it um
and now let me get to the so you can
sort of
correctly handle multiplicities and i
just want to push past that and let me
tell you the core of the recursive
construction in my final three minutes
so the construction is now just going to
take this low diameter clustering thing
and just use it inside a recursion so
we'll partition our graph into these
promised size pieces
um and then we're going to build the bfs
tree and collapse into a point that
gives us a new graph and we recurse
and my claim is if we set our parameters
right this will be
a low stroke spanning tree so the reason
for it is as follows what we're going to
do is we're going to look at how much an
edge can how stretched an edge is as a
function of sort of what level it gets
collapsed on
so the idea is um
if i tell you that i have a cluster of
radius r
then um
any edge
internal to the clusters think of the
bottom level
has is stretched by mostly right if i
take a breath for a search tree then i
don't stretch an edge too much by using
shortest pads it's done by the diameter
um if i'm at a higher level
then if i take an edge after i've
collapsed 12 times then each one of the
edges that i have corresponds to
a path of length d1 level below it so
what you get is that after i've done
this recursively i times and as in the
ice level can be stretched by a factor
of the diameter of each of these
clusters to the i
because each you know each left each um
edge at one level is a path of level
below it of it up to a diameter
um and so
uh now we're just going to bounce stuff
so the idea is that the um
work the number of edges at level i is
going to be
um
sorry just put all this up now and then
say what happens so the idea here is the
number of the edges at level i is going
to be
it's going to go down by t every level
because of the fraction of edges we're
cutting right so each level is supposed
to cut few of the edges
so the number of edges at level i is
like
falling off as the power
and then what we're going to do is just
choose the right value of we have one
parameter here the one parameter is t
like we can choose sort of how
aggressively to grow the balls versus
cut the edges
um and
um let's see what has what we get as a
function of tape
what we'll get is that level i is just
going to contribute
m times log to the i
so it's falling off fairly quickly
at the rate that kind of matches up with
it so i claim if we choose
t to be 2 to the o of root log and log
login i claim that we'll actually get
exactly the right proof so let me tell
you kind of morally what's going on here
because i think it's hard to do
recursions in three minutes so the idea
is that if i did log in levels of um the
standard parameters this usually is that
you remove half the edges every time and
you get login levels
that turns out not to be too useful
because you end up raising you end up
having this
uh diameter to the ninth power which
gives you something very big if i raise
it to a login
instead what we're gonna do
is we're going to be we're going to say
that to know if i look at d to the i
it's a lot more important not to make
high block but not to make d blow up so
we're going to make d
um
the diameter that we're shooting for
be a little bigger than log n we're
going to make it two to the root one
and this
if it's and then what we get for that
the biggest diameter's a little bigger
is we're actually going to get the
number of levels of recursion is only
going to be square root of log n that's
just some log log factors so we're gonna
do is we're gonna choose our parameters
so the number of levels of this
recursion is square root of log n
instead of log n
um and then and the reason we want to do
something like that is that you pay a
lot for the edges at the top level so
you want the number of edges in each
level to fall off really quickly so
we're going to make bigger diameter
clusterings a diameter that's like two
to the root log n it's just balancing
parameters but that's what happens so
that your edges the number of edges of
the levels fall off super quickly
um but each so now each cluster has
diameter to the root log n and you only
go up log in like root log n levels
um and that
gives us sort of our desired bound so
that's the high level the high level
point really to get so to get this kind
of down to get an m to the one plus
epsilon all you have to do is grow
breadth first search trees collapse into
points and repeat
uh the where the better constructions
come from is they look more like
fertility compositions
they actually have so they have to do a
probabilistic cutting procedure
they also have to do something like
bartology competitions but with
multiple metrics so they sort of have to
understand there's sort of an asymmetry
in this picture between
um
the
know that lengths of pads being long was
really bad for this so there's sort of
an asymmetry between the cluster
european and the other clusters they do
they grow stars instead of trees and it
takes some work you just do region
growing with the regions are not balls
anymore that's why
yeah but you need to do um two different
metrics
like you need to grow a ball in one
metric and then depending on those ten
point square regions
it's still a region growing argument but
it needs a little bit more work
um
anyway so that actually now is a full
linear system software um okay so um
that's it and i'm happy to answer any
let me take one questions in other words
thanks john
um